Gut.
Guten Abend.
Ich bin Mehmet Elitz.
Ich bin der Diensthabender auf diese Stadt schon und werde mit Ihnen Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir. Mir geht es wirklich nicht besonders gut.
Ich bin da für Sie.
Jetzt werde ich Ihnen helfen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Nicole Meyer.
Nicole Meyer.
Könnten Sie bitte langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname N-I-C-O-L-E.
Nicole und Meyer mit M-A-I-E-R.
Okay.
Herr Meyer.
Frau.
Frau Meyer.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57 Jahre.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 5.07.65.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Frau Meyer.
Ich bin 1,63 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie, wenn ich fragen darf?
Ja, ich wiege aktuell noch 71 kg.
71? Okay.
Okay, Frau Meyer. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Wie kann ich Ihnen erinnern?
Ja, also wissen Sie, Herr Doktor, ich habe seit drei Wochen habe ich eigentlich schon ziemlich kräftige Bauchschmerzen.
Immer nach dem Essen.
Ich habe immer gedacht, ja gut, dann darfst du halt nicht so viel essen und ein bisschen vorsichtig essen.
Und jetzt ist mir aber gestern ist mir aufgefallen, dass in meinem Stuhl, dass da Blut drin war.
Und das war mir dann doch ein bisschen unheimlich.
Und dann spät am Abend und auch heute am Tag, das war ganz merkwürdig, da sah der Stuhlgang so ganz schwarz aus.
Und ich habe auch wirklich kräftige Schmerzen, es wird immer mehr.
Und mir ist auch richtig schlecht.
Also mir ist wirklich übel und zurzeit schmeckt mir das Essen auch wirklich nicht besonders.
Also, ja, also ich bin ein bisschen unzufrieden mit mir.
Ja, ich verstehe, Frau Meyer. Ist Ihnen ein Übel auch?
Ja, mir ist schlecht, ja.
Okay, haben Sie schon mal erbrochen?
Nee, übergeben. Nein, habe ich mich nicht. Nein, nee, nee.
Okay.
Frau Meyer, sind die Schmerzen langsam begonnen oder war es...
Ja, die haben langsam angefangen und dann ist das immer heftiger geworden.
Wo würden Sie die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala einordnen?
Schauen Sie mal, null ist kein Schmerz, zehn ist wirklich unertragbare Schmerzen.
Boah, also die Schmerzen sind wirklich krass.
Also ich würde sagen, die sind so bei 7, 8, bei 8 sind die schon, ja.
7, 8. Das sind sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Können Sie aushalten bis zum Ende des Gesprächs oder?
Ja, also wenn ich so sitze, geht es, geht es, ja.
Ja, okay.
Aber wenn Sie irgendwann ein Schmerzmittel benötigen, dann geben Sie mir ein Bischof.
Ja, dann sage ich Ihnen Bischof.
Okay.
Frau Meyer, fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Fieberig fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht, nein.
Hallo, können Sie mir hören?
Jetzt kann ich Sie wieder hören, ja.
Okay.
War zwischendurch die Verbindung weg?
Sorry.
Ja.
Frau Meyer, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ab- oder Zurke genommen?
Haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich, in der letzten Zeit ist mir aufgefallen, ja, habe ich 2 kg abgenommen.
Ich war da gar nicht unglücklich darüber, aber es schmeckt mir auch gerade irgendwie gar nicht.
Ich habe, ich esse nicht besonders gerne, das ist alles ein bisschen doof.
Okay, verstehe.
Frau Meyer, haben Sie irgendwelche Auslöser für diese Beschwerden bemerkt?
Haben Sie irgendwelche Erklärung dafür?
Also los geht es eigentlich immer ganz besonders nach dem Essen, da ist es besonders rein.
Okay, was für ein bisschen, zum Beispiel, verteiliges Essen?
Ja, ja, ja, aber das vermeidet man dann ja eigentlich schon, weil man genau weiß, oh, das geht wieder schief, ne?
Okay.
Frau Meyer, strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus, zum Beispiel die Wolken oder Leichte dabei?
Nee, eigentlich sind die so auf dem oberen Bauch so konzentriert, würde ich sagen, ja.
Und immer da? Oder wellenfürmig?
Nee, also die Wellenförmig sind die nicht, sie haben sich langsam gesteigert und sie sind insbesondere, also krass nach dem Essen.
Okay, verstehe.
Dann klingen sie danach so ein bisschen wieder ab.
Okay.
Frau Meyer, ist ihr Stuhlgang schmerzhaft?
Nö, nicht schmerzhaft, ist das eigentlich nicht.
Nee, mir ist das jetzt nur aufgefallen, wie gesagt, das eine Mal, das hat mich auch ein bisschen erschreckt, dass da Blut drin war.
Kriegt man ja einen Schreck, ne?
Wie viel mal das war?
Ja, ich habe es mal einmal und dann gestern und heute dieser ganz schwarze Stuhlgang, das sah ja auch sehr komisch aus.
Okay.
Frau Meyer, haben Sie das Gefühl, so Toilette, so muss es ohne das etwas kommt?
Nee, das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, das habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher auch?
Nein, eigentlich habe ich solche Bauchschmerzen, so etwas kenne ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Okay.
Und beim Atmen, fäll in deren Runde verschwinden wir die Schmerzen, oder gibt es keinen Relevant?
Ich würde sagen, da gibt es keinen Unterschied.
Okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen, Frau Meyer?
Ja, klar, in meinem Alter, kein Wunder.
Also, ich habe ein bisschen Bluthochdruck und die Cholesterinwerte sind ein bisschen hoch.
Aber das habe ich halt, da kriege ich Medikamente und ich habe schon ewig lange eine Schuppenflechte.
Also insbesondere an den Oberarmen und an der Armbeuge und manchmal auch in den Kniekehlen.
Da muss ich halt dann so Salbe benutzen.
Und also Schmerzen hatte ich auch schon, aber das waren andere Bauchschmerzen.
Ich hatte Nierensteine.
Und das waren aber ganz andere Schmerzen.
Ja, Sie können unterschieden.
Das ist jetzt anders.
Und ich habe vor sechs Jahren dann so eine Haarleiterschiene bekommen.
Und dann hatte ich tatsächlich auch, ja, das ist jetzt schon ein halbes Jahr her.
Ja, ein gutes halbes Jahr, ist schon eine Weile länger.
Und dann hatte ich eine kleine Trombose im Unterschenkel.
Okay, nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Württverdünnern?
Jetzt nicht mehr, das ist alles abgesetzt.
Also ich hatte da Medikamente genommen und Strom getragen, aber das ist jetzt alles abgesetzt.
Also das ist jetzt wieder frei, die Wege.
Was war Ihre Entscheidung oder Ihre Art?
Der hat ja Art, der hat es kontrolliert.
Okay, okay, super.
Und was nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck und Hypocholisterinami?
Ja, ich nehme da so ein Statin.
Ich meine, das sind was Statin, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, was für eine Dosierung,
dann nehme ich abends eine.
Okay.
Und gegen den hohen Blutdruck, nehme ich Kandisatan.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Ich meine, das sind acht Milligramm, dann nehme ich morgens und abends eine.
Okay.
Ja, ich stehe.
Frau Meier, können Sie ausreichend schlafen?
Ja, also jetzt die letzten Tage mit den Bauchschmerzen habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen,
aber normalerweise kann ich eigentlich gut schlafen.
Und was mir jetzt in der letzten Zeit zu schaffen gemacht hat beim Einschlafen,
ich habe immer so Brinnen gehabt.
Sobald ich mich hingelegt habe, hatte ich das Gefühl,
oh, ja, da kommt es so sauer hoch.
Und das war nicht so angenehm.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Magenschutz oder solche Medikamente eingenommen?
Nee, das ist erst seit einigen Tagen, also das ist noch nicht so lange.
Da habe ich noch nichts gegen eingenommen.
Okay, verstehe.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Veränderungen im Urin bemerkt?
Im Urin habe ich nichts bemerkt.
Nee, das muss eigentlich alles normal sein.
Das sind in Ordnung, okay.
Okay, Frau Meier.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Ja, also wie gesagt, dieses Dudrum, keine Satan.
Ja, außer die Satin.
Dann das Statin.
Dann, ja, wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich Ibuprofen ein,
was, was ich, wenn man mal Kopfschmerzen hat oder so.
Und dann habe ich noch eben diese Cortison-Salve,
wenn das mit der Schuppenfläche unangenehm ist.
Okay.
Äh, ändern Sie sich daran, ob Sie in der letzten Zeit diese Ibuprofen
vermehrt ist, eingenommen?
Nee, gar nicht.
Ich hatte eigentlich keinen Anlass.
Nee, ich war jetzt irgendwie, habe nicht besonders viel eingenommen.
Okay.
Wo denn Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, außer diese Hahnleiterschiene,
das ist ja nicht so eine richtige Operation,
bin ich noch nicht operiert.
Okay, gut.
Und rauchen Sie?
Noch mal bitte.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ja, ja, ich rauche.
Ja, seit 20 Jahren rauf ich.
Wie viel Zigaretten rauchen Sie täglich?
Ja, seit 15 sind das schon.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol.
Also, ein, zwei Schlaschen Bier am Abend trinke ich so.
Okay.
Und Sie haben allergische Haut, außer diese Schuppflächten.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie?
Ja, also bekannt ist eigentlich nur,
dass ich auf braunes Pflaster allerges bin.
What?
Braunes Pflaster.
Ah, ja.
Da kriege ich so rote Pünktchen, so das Jucktal.
Ja, sehr, sehr.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft, auch gegen Corona?
Gegen Corona bin ich ganz sicher vollständig geimpft.
Alles andere, ja,
meine ich, dass ich da relativ auf dem Laufenden bin, ja.
Okay.
Frau Meier,
ich lebe in Ihrer Eltern noch.
Meine Mutter lebt noch, ja.
Und mein Vater ist bei einem Verkehrsunfall schon vor vielen Jahren
ums Leben gekommen.
Ich lebe in der Mutter.
Und hat Ihre Mutter irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ja, im Augenblick,
ich vermute, dass die so eine Verschlusskrankheit hat.
Die hat so ein offenes Bein.
Und das wird behandelt.
Und da ist man gerade eigentlich dabei zu gucken,
was da die Ursache ist.
Okay, verstehe.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet,
aber ich habe keine eigene Kinder, das sind Stiefkinder.
Ja, okay.
Hatten Sie Kinderwunsch, oder?
Ne, hat sich irgendwie nicht ergeben in meinem Leben.
Okay.
Wann war Ihre letzte Blutung?
Erinnern Sie sich daran?
Oh, das ist, ja, so mit Anfang 50, also fünf Jahre her.
Okay.
Sie haben kein genügend logisches Problem, oder?
Nein, ich gereglehmete sie zur Krebsvorsorge.
Also einmal im Jahr, sozusagen zum TÜV.
Aber da ist nie irgendwas Besonderes.
Ich habe schon meine alle wichtige Frage gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzubegen, oder haben wir etwas vergessen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir etwas vergessen haben.
Sie haben ja viel gefragt und ich habe Ihnen noch eine Menge erzählt.
Jetzt möchte ich natürlich schon wissen,
woher das denn kommen kann, diese Schmerzen.
Und was man dagegen machen kann, ob man das zügig irgendwie behandeln kann,
ob man Medikamente daneben kann, oder was man tun kann.
Ja, klar.
Ich hatte einige Frage, darf ich?
Ein Moment.
Ein Moment, sagt doch doch.
Was ist das für eine Medikamente?
Natürlich habe ich, der Dr. Diagnose, aber zuerst muss ich sie auszulichern,
völlig untersuchen.
Es kann um eine Darmbulutung oder Magin-Bulutung handeln.
Ich werde ein paar Untersuchungen wie Blutabnahme und Stuhlprobe
und möglicherweise,
wahrscheinlich werden wir ein Darmspiegelung durchführen.
Das ist nicht so schön, ne?
Ja, das kann unangenehm sein,
aber das ist wichtig für Sie.
Manu können mir bereits wichtige Rückschlüsse über Ihre Erkrankung ziehen.
Muss ich Sie in deinem Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja, Sie müssen bei uns bleiben.
Ja, okay, dann muss ich mein Mann anrufen,
dass er mir die Sachen bringt.
Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorge,
dass Sie in einem Krankenhaus sind, bekommen Sie von uns alles.
Ah, okay, das ist auch gut, ja.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Bikischen Kollegen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzgrasen oder ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Momentan.
Nein, beides nicht.
Haben Sie Schluckstörungen?
Nein, ich habe Schluckstörungen,
dass ein Teil, das Sie geschildert hat,
dass Sie so bringen hat.
Okay, danke.
Können Sie dich, Mersen, generalbescheid,
und Sie sind am ersten drückend?
Drückend.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen
nach dem Essen aufgetreten und danach weggegangen
oder immer da?
Weniger geworden sind, weniger.
Also immer nach dem Essen ist es besonders schlecht,
und danach wird es ein bisschen besser.
Können Sie, wie stark sind Sie, Mersen, am Anfang,
nach dem Essen und danach?
Direkt nach dem Essen sind Sie bei acht,
und nachher sind Sie vielleicht noch bei sechs oder fünf oder so.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Ihr habt eine Frage?
Ja, gerne.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ja, genau.
Ich bin Buchhändlerin.
Auch noch.
Haben Sie unter Stress?
Bei der Arbeit?
Ja, wir hatten ein bisschen Stress in der Corona-Zeit,
aber jetzt läuft ja alles wieder.
Und der Stress kommt jetzt in der Weihnachtszeit erst.
Im Augenblick ist noch kein Stress.
Bücher sind hier etwas sehr Schönes.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben zwei Kilo abgenommen.
In welcher Zeitraum haben Sie zwei Kilo abgenommen?
Zwei Kilo in zwei Wochen.
Danke schön.
Ja, gerne.
Bevor Sie das geredet haben, haben Sie schon gesagt,
und Mehmet hat gefragt, keine?
War nicht vorher.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie ein bis zwei Bier am Abend,
jeden Tag getrunken.
Andere getrunken, und wie viel Jahre?
Eigentlich schon ewig lange.
Mal ein Bier, mal zwei Bier am Abend.
Aber eigentlich regelmäßig seit vielen Jahren.
Können wir anfangen?
Mehmet, heißt das?
Ja, das ist die Fürschung her.
Danke schön.
Guten Abend Frau Oberasten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen,
und ich möchte über sie Ihnen berichten.
Eine 57-jährige Patientin Nicole Meier hat sich heute bei uns
wegen seit ca. zwei Wochen allmählich aufgetretene,
bestehende Abdomenschmerzen vorgegeben.
Die Schmerzen legen bei sieben bis acht auf der Schmerzschkale.
Die Patientin berichtete, dass die Schmerzen besonders nach
dem Essen besonders fitreichiges Essen aufgetreten seien.
Die Patientin berichtete auch T-Stuhl.
Einmal habe sie Blutigestuhl gesehen.
Wie ist der Fachbegriff?
Melena für den T-Stuhl.
Was ist das für die Patientin?
Die Patientin hat sie innerhalb von zwei Wochen abgenommen.
Sie haben in Appetenz die Frage nach Fieber und Brächen verneint.
Sie haben keine Disfakie, aber sie fühlt sich übernäuse.
Sie haben eine Erkrankung, die unter Alteurella Hypertone leidet.
Sie nehmen Kandesatan, 8 mg, morgens und abends.
Vor sechs Jahren wurde bei der Patientin eine Heimleiteschiene
wegen der Steine eingesetzt.
Sie haben die Patientin von Brumbo gesehen.
Aber sie nehmen keine Medikamente mehr.
Das ist schon abgesetzt.
Sie haben eine Familie.
Sie haben ihre Mutter.
Sie haben keine festgestellte Erkrankung.
Sie ist Raucher.
Sie haben 15 Zigaretten täglich und trinken 1-2 Bier abends.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Sie haben eine Intestinalbelutung.
Und sie kann auch fulgustfremdgekürlich sein.
Sie haben eine Erkrankung, die sie ausführlich und körperlich untersucht.
Sie haben eine Erkrankung, die sie abtastet.
Sie haben eine Erkrankung, die sie ausführlich untersucht.
Und wahrscheinlich werde ich durchführen.
Und eventuell werde ich eine Koloskopie durchführen oder beanlassen.
Koloskopie oder was wäre alternativ noch interessant?
Ist es wahrscheinlich, dass die Blutung im Darm sitzt?
Wenn sie Melena hat.
Ja, ganz in gesamter Darm und Magen werde ich als...
Wir müssen also von oben auch gucken.
Das Koloskopie und Gastroskopie und Gastrodönoskopie und Koloskopie.
Beides, genau.
Von jeder Richtung einfach gucken.
Ja, genau.
Okay, und wonach würden sie dann...
Was würden sie noch für eine Untersuchung machen, um die Ursache unter Umständen zu ermitteln?
Meinen Sie im Blut oder im Stuhl?
Ich meine eigentlich...
Röntgen, Abdornen.
Abdornen haben Sie ja schon gesagt, würde man erstmal Sonografie machen.
Und dann eigentlich eher gucken, was bei der ÖGD und bei der Koloskopie rauskommt.
Nee, ich habe eigentlich mehr so einen Helikobacter.
Ah ja, Ureas Schnelltest.
Genau.
Und wenn der positiv ist, was kommt dann zu tragen?
Ja, dann gibt es zwei verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Italienische und Französische Möglichkeiten.
Triple, okay, alles klar.
Brauchen wir weiter zu fragen.
Wenn es negativ ist, was machen Sie?
Was empfehlen Sie der Patientin dann?
Ein Vietassistentin kann ich auch empfehlen.
Und Magenschutz werde ich verschreiben.
Wenn es ein Komplikation gäbe, werde ich auch chirurgisches Konzil antworten.
Auf alle Fälle, genau.
Ja, genau.
Ja, hier war jetzt nochmal nachgehalten.
Also, was für die Diagnose, was für die Diagnose, okus vertricoli spricht,
waren zwei besondere Faktoren hervorgehoben.
Was spricht insbesondere für die Diagnose?
Ernährung, meinen Sie, oder?
Auslöse oder?
Ja, genau. Die Post fand die einen Schmerzen.
Genau, das ist das erste.
Und das zweite war Reflexfragment.
Das hat einen Namen, das habe ich wieder vergessen.
Fyrosis heißt das.
Ja, Fyrosis.
Wir mussten ja die Fachbegriffe bedienen.
Das war aber nur einmal.
Sie hat gesagt, das hindert sie beim Schlafen.
Hat sie gesagt.
Gut.
Und hier war noch gefragt, was für eine Komplikation kann im Rahmen der
Gastroskopie auftreten?
Natürlich auch im Rahmen der Chronoskopie.
Ja, Perforation.
Das waren genau die Punkte, die hier angesprochen waren.
Ja, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, wie es Frau Meier geht,
und was Sie rausgefunden haben.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass es der Patientin bald besser geht.
Ja, sehr schön.
Perfekt.
Ich glaube, Sie haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Und Sie haben auch eine gute Präsentation gemacht.
Vielleicht noch so ein ganz klein bisschen darauf achten,
dass Sie die Fachbegriffe verwenden im Arztgespräch.
Ich habe das nicht so richtig begriffen, Herr Gündiz.
Ist das neulich da in Dessau?
Ist das bemängelt worden, dass die zu viel oder zu wenig
Fachbegriffe verwendet hat?
Ich bin der Schreiben vieler Fachbegriff benutzt,
aber Arztgespräch ist normal.
Aber dieser Bechdender, aber Prokredienter.
Prokredienter, und Epigastisch.
Epigastisch, das ist tatsächlich so ein...
Das wollte ich sagen, aber ich konnte nicht daran erinnern.
Hier ist neuseher, keine Gomitus, und so weiter.
Also das soll man im Gespräch nicht unbedingt verwenden.
Ja, aber nicht.
Ich bin echt davon ausgegangen, dass das gefordert ist,
dass sie das wollen, dass man das im Arztgespräch verwenden.
Aber das ist ja völlig idiotisch.
Eine Prüfer hat gesagt, warum viele Fachbegriffe benutzen.
Zum Beispiel, eine Kollegin hat gesagt, der Patient hat Neuseher und Gomitus.
Warum Neuseher?
Neuseher, nicht Übelkeit, sagen Sie.
Aber das ist doch Willkür, das ist doch Willkür der Prüfer,
was die machen, mal ganz ehrlich.
In einem Fall sagen Sie, verwenden Sie Fachbegriffe,
und im anderen Fall sagen Sie, warum reden Sie nicht Deutsch mit mir?
Also sorry, da muss man ja hell sehen als Prüfling.
Eine Arzt hat gesagt, Abdominasi.
Der Prüfer hat gesagt, nicht Abdominasi,
das ist doch Schmerzen.
Eine Torekalschmerz, nein, nicht Torekalschmerz.
Ja, gut, Torekalschmerzen kann man ja vielleicht gerade noch so hin,
oder Abdominal Schmerzen, kann man vielleicht auch sagen.
Aber das kommt mir ein bisschen verrückt vor.
Klar, im Arzt-Patientengespräch muss man die deutschen Begriffe nehmen.
Das ist ja völlig logisch, klar.
Wie soll der Patient, die sonst verstehen?
Aber im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch muss es eigentlich legitim sein,
die Fachbegriffe zu verwenden.
Und ich meine, dass ich das von einigen Leuten vorher gehört habe,
dass sie gesagt haben, wir müssen die Fachbegriffe verwenden.
Ja, ich denke, wir müssen Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch und Begriff schreiben,
Fachbegriff schreiben.
Da muss man vielleicht ein ganz klein bisschen rausfühlen,
was will der Patient verhören.
Und wenn der also ein Gesicht zieht,
wenn sie das erste Mal den Fachbegriff nehmen,
oder umgekehrt, wenn sie das deutsche Wort sagen,
dann korrigieren sie halt oder sagen,
was, was ich den anderen Begriff und nehmen beim nächsten Mal
das, was er hören will.
Also wichtig ist eigentlich, dass die Fachbegriffe
in dieser allerersten Schilderung eigentlich kommen.
Ich denke, da ist es relativ entscheidend.
Und hinterher muss man halt ein ganz klein bisschen
von der aktuellen Stimmung dann vor Ort abhängig machen.
Aber ich meine, dass sie überhaupt keine Schwierigkeiten haben,
gut auf Deutsch zu formulieren.
Und auch auf Nachfragen zu reagieren.
Und ich sprachlich überhaupt keine Schwierigkeiten geben.
Ja, würde ich sagen.
Ja, aber ich sage mal inzwischen,
meine unmaßgebliche Meinung.
Weil es ist ja wirklich, ich habe schon so viele in Leuten gesagt,
ich bin bonten sicher, dass sie ihre Prüfung bestehen.
Und dann kommt irgendwie so ein Prüfer
und hat irgendwie so eine Idee,
dass er was Bestimmtes hören oder nicht hören will.
Ja, Himmelhilfe.
Dann bin ich natürlich auch machtlos.
Aber ich würde so nach unserem Gespräch,
nach dem, was wir jetzt gemacht haben, sagen,
das ist alles in trockenen Tüchern.
Und sie sind sehr, sehr sicher im Gespräch und in der Formulierung.
Ja.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Ja.